people always ask me if i liked growing  up in a big family for those of you that  don't know i have nine siblings so the  way that i describe being in a big  family is there are highs and lows the  highs are so high when i think of our  vacations that everyone got along like  they're some of my favorite memories but  the lows are also very low with more  people there's always gonna be more  drama  because there's more personalities so  we're obviously gonna have more drama  than a family with like two kids but i  think it's worth it there's always  something to do i always have someone to  hang out with and i can't imagine i  can't imagine having as much fun as we  do in a small family